depuis le début des bombardements
meurtriers art active ces équipes de
démineurs travaillent sans relâche
car ici dans la deuxième ville du pays
des bombes à sous munitions comme celles
ci sont disséminés un peu partout y
compris dans les zones résidentielles
le danger partout jusqu'à 40% de ces
mini bombes larguées sur les villes
n'explose pas à l'impact et reste au sol
les démineurs comme igor of shahrukh
doivent les récupérer les désamorcer une
à une ici le missile a atterri dans un
jardin d'enfants
les obus sont ensuite entassés à
l'extérieur de la ville
depuis le début de la guerre on extrait
departed objet explosif des rues de
quartiers on a trouvé des obus des
systèmes de missiles ouragans et ce
match c'est avec ça qu'ils ont bombardé
les positions de nos troupes mais
beaucoup se sont abattues sur les
bâtiments civils d'attaché pression
sur ces images les effets d'une bombe à
sous-munitions conçu pour détruire un
large périmètre
à la différence de la plupart des bombes
les armes à sous munitions ne
contiennent pas une seule charge
explosive mais plusieurs dizaines ou
centaines des perrés en grappe on les
remarque par la présence de conteneurs
vides qui retombe au hasard au milieu
des routes et y reviendrai tous deux
zones contrôlées par les russes
les nations unies brandissent la menace
de poursuites contre mosson nous avons
reçu des rapports crédibles
d'utilisation d'armes à sous-munitions
par les forces russes y compris dans des
zones habitées
les attaques indiscriminées celles
utilisant des bombes à sous munitions
sont interdites par le droit humanitaire
international
mais contrairement à une centaine de
pays dans le monde l'ukraine et la
russie n'ont pas signé le traité
d'interdiction des armes à sous
munitions